the Wagner paramilitary groups claim
that it has captured Baku could not be
clearer we've seen pictures of its
Fighters waving flags on top of
devastated buildings triumphantly and it
is a significant moment although it is
unlikely to be a defining one Russian
forces have spent an enormous amount of
resource trying to capture what is
effectively a small mining town if you
look at the pictures of the city it's in
absolute ruination virtually every
building has been destroyed Russia has
also lost tens of thousands of troops
trying to capture it it is though a
significant blow to the ukrainians
because they've also used up a lot of
resource trying to defend it but it is
unlikely to decide the outcome of this
conflict it's not of no strategic value
but its strategic value is limited the
focus now of course will be on Ukraine's
coming counter offenses if it's success
or failure is much more likely to have a
big impact on the trajectory of this war